welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
was James Gunn's conclusion to its
Guardian Saga in the MCU a narrative
that he didn't always have full control
over leading to some interesting logical
inconsistencies or plot holes in his
final chapter why didn't Star-Lord Peter
Quill use his helmet to survive that
final spacewalk from the high
evolutionary ship to Nowhere in Avengers
endgame Peter had his mask back again
has tweeted that Peter left the helmet
in his desk drawer while in a hurry to
leave but if you watch this movie
closely there's an even more powerful
reason he doesn't use it so we're gonna
explore the timeline of the canonicity
of this franchise and how the final
minutes of this movie are even cooler
than we realize Now new rockstars is now
a network of three channels this main
Channel my film analysis side Venture in
the Deep dive where I actually re broke
down the Guardians Trilogy and the
Matrix this week and then now the newly
launched break room Channel please
subscribe to all three and to support
this whole network grab something from
our merch store nerd riot.shop like this
rocket science 89p13 design from the
deep dive collection okay let's talk
about Peter's helmet among star-lord's
gear is a retractable mask that he wore
throughout the 2014 Guardians of the
Galaxy film he wore it again in 2017's
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 but while
fighting his father ego this helmet fell
off his face in broken pieces that's why
in the final acts of that movie yondu
has to give Peter his spacesuit to allow
him to breathe in open space previously
Peter's helmet would allow him to fly
around in space we saw him do that in
the first film while flying back from
the Kiln to grab his Walkman to catch
back up with the Milano and when he flew
outside nowhere offering his mask to
Gamora so that she could survive but
then came Avengers Infinity War which
technically takes place four years after
Guardians volume 2. in that time the
Guardians have upgraded to a new ship
the Benetar Groot has aged up in a
teenage group Peter gruesome new facial
hair and throughout Infinity War he uses
a new helmet that he presumably rebuilt
during those four years James Gunn did
not direct Divinity War or endgame the
Russo brothers did but Gunn is credited
as a producer on both films and
consulted on the guardian scenes for
those films he just didn't have final
creative Authority on the story which is
probably why Gamora gets killed off an
Infinity War now Peter Quill does an
Infinity War but when he returns an
endgame he's once again wearing the mask
and he wears it in the scene where he
reunites with Gamora we didn't see Peter
wear his mask at any point in Thor 11
Thunder which was directed by taikuy
Titi or in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special which was directed by
James Gunn so this kind of led to two
different realities one continuity over
scene by James Gunn in which Peter Quill
no longer uses this mask one overseen by
the russos in the Marvel Studios Brain
Trust in which he does far more people
saw Infinity war in in-game than people
who remember Peter wasn't wearing his
mask in those brief scenes of doorland
thunder and in the holiday special and
it's been years since we saw that brief
shot in volume 2 of his mask breaking
and we are just psychologically wired to
see reality as the presence of something
than the absence of it and so when Peter
leaps into the void of space it just
really bugs some people why Peter would
do that without a stressy helmet that
everyone remembers him having in
Avengers end game so when asked about
this on Twitter James Gunn responded
quote it's in his desk drawer in nowhere
he had to get out of there fast as you
know and for the next question people
ask the rockets that clip onto his boots
are far inferior to the jetpack's rocket
has made them so they're not around at
all anymore because I guess people were
also asking why Peter doesn't have his
rocket thrusters on his boots someone
further down the thread reminded people
that Peter's mask broken volume two but
then Gunn responded it did but then he
somehow had a new one in Infinity War
somehow which you can't help but hear as
somehow Palpatine returned now Gunn Has
Told The Hollywood Reporter that in
reference to Infinity war and end game
quote they did some things that I
wouldn't have wanted he said Star-Lord
would have killed Gamora if she asked
him to but he would not have punched
Thanos to Doom the universe that could
be how we get this moment in volume 3
where Peter comments on the events of
those movies yeah she was my girlfriend
only she doesn't remember it because it
wasn't her because her dad threw off a
magic cliff and she died and then I lost
my temper and nearly destroyed half the
universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know that's some freaking
infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass Earth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died
and then came back a total dick
got some important information
that is the gist of it now may is
cost month it's sunny out perfect
temperature you want to be outside and
you can maximize your time outside by
minimizing your time in the kitchen with
Factor factors fresh never frozen meals
are ready in two minutes just heat and
enjoy and then go back to walking your
dog factor is America's number one ready
to eat meal kit in other videos you
might have heard me talking about also
using hellofresh but that's because
factor is now owned by hellofresh and I
use both my life is easier and tastier
Factor lets me skip the trip to the
grocery store skip choppy and Skip
prepping and Skip cleaning up plus
Factor has more than 34 weekly options
so I never get tired of what I'm eating
Factor also now offers Gourmet plus
meals as part of your weekly option so
if you're craving something special you
get something special for sides you also
get premium produce like broccoli
broccolini to perfectly complement your
protein which can be Surf and surf
that's shrimp and salmon or surf and
turf shrimp and steak and I can tell you
from personal experience even after
reheating that steak it's so good it's
not dry it's not tough it is just good
this month I got some creamy jalapeno
chicken it was so delicious it's so easy
to make and it really just made my day
creamy cheesy jalapeno chicken
so head to factor75.com or click the
link below and use the code rockstars40
to get 40 off your first Factor box once
again that's factor75.com and use code
rockstars40 to get 40 off your first
Factor box actually James Gunn's
decision to have nebula give rocket the
vibranium arm of Bucky Barnes in the
holiday special kind of feels like
revenge for the studio screwing with his
character's lives and now the people
making Captain America 4 and
Thunderbolts are gonna have to scramble
to justify this or just ignore it I
don't think it's implausible that Peter
would have left his mask in his drawer
on nowhere he was drunk in the opening
act within hours of nebula having to
carry him home by the way gun revealed
that that was a Chris Pratt dummy that
weighed 35 pounds and that is so awesome
that that's my for real proportions
that's what I look like that's you but
what may be harder for you to buy is
that Peter would take that leap of faith
without having his helmet did he forget
that he didn't have it was this really
just done to structure in a victory for
Adam Warlock to justify him joining the
team in the final minutes of the movie
well sure Peter and Adam recreating
Michelangelo's creation of Adam was no
accident Peter is descended from a God
and you could see this as Adam's
activation moment but there is more
going on here when you re-watch this
scene frame by frame Peter only went
back for that Zune before Cosmo fainted
and the bridge broke but of course he
wouldn't leave it behind after ego broke
the Walkman the Zune with its music
compiled by yondu is the only parental
link Peter has left and Peter actually
makes a really smart tactical
improvisation here he rips the fluid
hose off the bulkhead and he takes it
with him into space he released his tiny
bursts to continue to propel him just
like Wally does with fire extinguisher
or Mark Watley does with the slash in
his spacesuit in the Martian and once
Peter is aimed correctly he releases the
entire hose and uses Newton's third law
shedding him forward now debris slows
him down but in a few seconds we get to
see how Peter Quill both still loves
yondu and is capable of smart on-the-fly
engineering Solutions the way rocket
always pulls off he uses his heart and
his brain grabs a zoo because he knows
rocket will need this spiritual guidance
as the next captain of the Guardians
this whole movie is about saving the
universe by saving one friend so why
doesn't quill use his helmet because he
drunkenly forgot it in a drawer but also
because he has evolved enough as a hero
to no longer need his shell Iron Man
wasn't helmeted when he made the
sacrifice play Peter Parker didn't wear
his mask when Doctor Strange completes
the memory wipe spell these heroes are
not toys they're people and in these
finales it's more cinematic to see these
people's faces get [__] up hey on
Friday May 26 in Los Angeles I'm going
to join Tommy bechtold and Jessica
Clemens and the new rock stars Crew live
on stage with special guests some crazy
bits and some exclusive stuff that we
can never show on YouTube for in-person
tickets click the link in the
description below you can also stream
the worldwide digital experience from
our partners at moment that link is also
in the description you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow me
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign